and speaking of people who have things
working in their favor
it was recently reported that u.s
postmaster general louis de joy
has awarded a massive contract the post
office has awarded a massive contract he
swears he wasn't involved in the process
but they have awarded a massive contract
to a company called
xpo logistics and those who have you
who have been following excuse me louis
dejoy's story
for the past year i'm sure that company
name certainly rings a bell right
because xbo logistics happens to be the
company that louis de joy
up until october held a massive
financial interest in
but he divested from that company in
october
kind of citizens for responsibility and
ethics in washington
says that this is really a sham
divestment
because all he did was give all of his
holdings to his
children who in turn will most likely
just give it all back to him
once he is no longer the post master
general of the united states and again
the contracts being steered towards expo
that dejoy swears he didn't have a hand
in total 120
million dollars which could result in a
net windfall for the dejoy family
of 23 million
dollars so the big question everybody
has of course is
why is louis de joy still the postmaster
general of the united states
and the answer is because man the post
office infrastructure is set up weird
that is honestly the best way i can
describe it
going through and i'm not sure if david
has explained this but i'm going to go
ahead and explain it in a
really slimmed down version here but to
just sum it up
um incredibly hard to remove a
postmaster general
here's what's happening biden cannot
fire louis de joy
he is powerless to stop to joy but what
he can do
is he can appoint new members to the
board of governors
of which he's already nominated three
they have not been approved
and then the board of governors are the
ones who get to
vote to oust the postmaster general
here's a problem though there's three
vacancies biden's nominated people for
those
and if and when they get approved
democrats
will have the majority on that board of
governors
so you would think at that point that
dejoy's history right
nope because two of the democrats
on that board of governors were
appointed by trump
and those same two democrats actually
voted in favor
of this new deal so if they're okay with
it
they they're okay with the joy
so biden can get his people there
democrats will have the majority but
they still
probably not going to remove him at that
point so then what's the remedy
well i'm glad you asked the remedy is
biden can
fire members of the governor's board
with
cause now that little statement with
cause or four calls i think is how it's
phrased um very difficult
because cause can mean anything and
cause can mean nothing
and cause can be a very specific
incident depending on which court
is looking at it and that's what's so
worrisome here
firing these individuals for not
removing louis de joy for a very obvious
conflict of interest
would be considered cause
depending on which court hears this case
now does it have to go before a court
absolutely not
but if these individuals sue alleging
that there is no cause it would go in
front of a court
and the experts have pretty much agreed
that's what would happen if by
if biden fired any of these individuals
so we are effectively
stuck for the moment i know we'd like to
think that biden could do something
about this but honestly
this is one of those times where his
hands are tied
and it sucks so bad that that is the
position that we are in
but unfortunately it is the position
that we are in
and the joy it appears is going to
continue to use this position
to make as much money as possible for
when that day comes
when he's no longer the postmaster
general and
to me that day can't come soon enough
but i'm worried that it may not come
anytime soon
i am fair and cousins in for david
pakman and don't forget
you can get even more from me on my
youtube channels youtube.com slash the
ring of
slash fair fire balanced and i'm on
twitter facebook and instagram at
fair and balanced we'll be right back
with more of the david pakman show
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid
but without the sugar or the carbs every
serving of magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar only four net carbs
140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto
perfect if you're doing low carb great
if you're just trying to reduce your
excess sugar intake and because it's
packed with protein
it's great before or after a workout
magic spoon flavors include cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
and cinnamon
they're bringing back cookies and cream
they're bringing back
maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all
magic spoon is so confident in the
product if you don't love it as much as
i do they will refund your money no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video
and you'll get five dollars off when you
use the promo code
pacman at checkout